what's being alleged is that you know
two contestants were so inebriated that
they can't remember what they did and
that the producers maybe should have
stepped in rope given what you know from
your time in paradise could you see a
situation like that happening I don't
think that they would let something
actually like really bad happen
you know they would step in like I said
you know they would pull me aside every
ten minutes and make sure I wasn't gonna
rip someone's head off I just I'm gonna
make out with you know I may know anyone
tonight it's what we remember most about
Chad's time in paradise
the cup in his hand and the bad behavior
that seemed to be fueled by alcohol but
was it a case of Chad just being bad or
if the drinking on the show encouraged
by producers you got pretty drunk wrong
when you were there what happened set
the scene for me when you get to
paradise are you immediately given a
drink I had drank a whole bottle of wine
and like six or seven shots before we
even started filming but I asked for it
you know okay I didn't mean to do that
much but I did it you know they didn't
they didn't tell me to drink any of it
so it's it's just it's like going to an
open bar you know nobody's going to tell
you at an open bar stop drinking is it
ever you know encourage like hey why
don't you have another one no no I don't
believe so they never happened to me
Chad famously had some intense moments
of his own during his short stay on the
show picking fights and hanging out in
the sand do you think that they let the
sort of like incident or drama play out
too far like to a point where they
should step in but they're not they're
almost like putting the drama ahead of
the safety of the cast I think they're
they're relying on what you know they
they found out about you through all the
psychology tests I tell them I'm not
going to hurt anybody I'm not going to
actually hit anybody you know and I was
like you know all day though I'm going
to make them think I will and they were
like you know fantastic what am I going
to do
[Music]
he managed to parlay his moments of
infamy into a new gig
Chad's now starring on ease famously
single so how does he feel about his
stint in paradise now I regret drinking
so much you know in real life if I drink
that much I would have just gone to bed
or fallen asleep but in that scenario
you have this adrenaline pump and so it
happens you know and like on The
Bachelorette you know you can see I
barely drink at all
[Music]